you know those are this extraordinary uh
conversation that I remember and a
journey to to Highgrove one weekend when
Harry would have been about six I played
or seven Harry William a little bit
older and an argument being refereed by
the nanny in the back seat Diana driving
and suddenly when there was a piece of
quiet you know Harry lent across and
said to William it's all right for you
you know you'll be king one day and I
went therefore I can do what I want now
that was 30 odd years ago and that is
exactly now what he's doing and and in a
way
given the circumstances that and the
Fallout of his relationship with the
royal family at the time of his wedding
in 2017. you know there's you know
there's a Revenge issue here really you
know he's actually in his words trying
to put you know the record straight I
mean one thing that that Harry's lacked
is somebody to give him advice there's
no convener here that he's very much on
his own out there and and Diana would
have understood completely the reasons
why he left for America May well have
even have encouraged it but insofar as
the book and the interview is concerned
she herself would have realized that it
was a mistake it was a mistake yes we
know historically you know we we
cemented all that we knew it happened
but I I think she would have been wise
enough from her own experiences later
Harry Hassan look I love you but this
isn't a good idea